[Music]
okay good afternoon thanks for coming my
name is Greg Braille I'm a software
engineer at Google
I've been part of the team that works on
the Apogee API management platform for
about 12 years I've been at Google a
little more than two years I'll be
joined later by Keith Daniken who works
in our field and that's gonna help me
with some demos and the main thing we're
gonna talk about today is we're gonna
talk about API so we're gonna talk about
things that companies have done with
api's we're gonna show some examples of
that we're gonna talk about the business
for about 10 minutes then we're gonna
get into a little bit about what API
management technology looks like and
what people are able to do with it so
there's our agenda but better than look
at the agenda slide that's just get
started
so these are examples of companies who
have had real business results by using
API is either by creating API programs
that are used by third parties by
creating new digital experiences with
api's or by essentially taking advantage
of the of the ability to use an API as a
layer on top of legacy technology for
instance Starbucks has a mobile app that
people use for buying coffee and they
also have some interesting digital
wallet capabilities that app runs on an
API that is layered on top of Starbucks
Starbucks legged if technology legacy
technology I'll get better as this goes
on similarly a company called arity is
actually in the business-to-business
business and what they've been able to
use is by having an API program rather
than sort of the old-fashioned way of
getting partners signed up that takes
months and months to have conversations
and emails and and powerpoints and
things but having a self-service API
their partners can get on-boarded in
just a few days or even a few hours this
is an example of some of the ways the
customers have been taking advantage of
this API technology that we all know
from the internet applying it to their
businesses and getting some real results
API is an API management has been around
for a while we've been talking about it
for a long time
the term API of course is you know 40
years old I'm really talking here about
a web api so the kind of 8 the ice that
run on the internet the kind of API is
you use
when you interface with Google cloud or
with third-party services like Twitter
or even Facebook most companies that
start out with API is kind of start out
on the lower left here they need to
solve some integration problems I need
to connect a new technology platform to
an old technology platform I want to
make it easy to build something like a
mobile app and sort of on the the two
boxes on the lower left-hand corner this
is what people were doing six or seven
years ago they were doing things like
putting an API layer in front of a
legacy app so that mobile developers
could use technology they understood
like JSON and HTTP to build a new
experience for their existing legacy
technology but what started to happen is
for one just having a mobile app wasn't
enough now we have things like connected
devices and smart speakers and connected
cars and talking refrigerators and
things like that and all of those kinds
of things require some sort of API
behind them when you say ok Google buy
me tickets for the Lady Gaga concert
that's only possible if the company
that's selling those tickets actually
has some sort of API for Google home to
speak to so fancy marketing term but
instead of talking about building apps
now we talk about creating digital
experiences but the companies that have
really done interesting things with
api's have used api's to create new
business models and create marketplaces
and platforms and I'll talk about some
examples one great example we have is
magaluf formerly known as magazine Luiza
it's the largest retailer in Brazil
they'll be speaking later at the
conference we'll put up a list of some
of the sessions later on mag Alou is a
brick and mortar retailer with stores
all over Brazil and a couple of years
ago they began transforming their
business by changing from a traditional
retailer to one that has very strong
capabilities around the web and around
mobile apps but in recent years they've
gone even farther now they have a
platform so third-party sellers
logistics providers all kinds of people
can both put put products in their
stores take advantage of their network
of stores and their distribution
capabilities to sell their products as
well as build other ways to integrate
with their with their infrastructure
essentially this kind of makes Magna
lewd the Amazon of Brazil which is funny
because Brazil already has an Amazon but
it's something that's actually given
them
huge business results and actually huge
results in their stock price as well
another great example of AccuWeather
also speaking here at the conference
AccuWeather we all know AccuWeather in
the united states as being you know the
person who the weatherman on television
gets information from but that weather
person on television um is only part of
what they do they also have an api that
gets 40 to 50 billion api calls a day
from all sorts of digital devices and
connected devices that want to show you
the weather but the interesting thing is
that their business is actually much
more than that there are businesses such
as insurance and financial services risk
management reinsurance all kind of
businesses like that that the weather
weather events have a big impact on
their business so AccuWeather is able to
sell more valuable you know basically
more expensive forecast products
tailored to those industries and the
fact that if they can have an api
platform that allows people to sign up
and get those products via self-service
by clicking a button on a website
signing up for an api paying some money
and using that API they can get
customers to use those systems much more
quickly than they might have in the past
last example I'll give you as
Ticketmaster in the United States we
know Ticketmaster is one of the
companies you go to to buy tickets but
an interesting stat is that at least 10%
of the traffic of the numbers of tickets
that are sold on Ticketmaster are not
sold directly from ticket masters
website or their mobile app but from
third parties for instance there are
hotels who when you make your hotel
reservation they say hey you'll be in
New York next week how about tickets to
frozen these kinds of things actually
happen using the API and again it's a
great example of a company like
Ticketmaster using api's to allow third
parties to drive new businesses on top
of their platform the reason why this
kind of thing can work is that these
companies treat api's not as a bit of
technology or about you know hey isn't
it cool that I can send you JSON and get
tickets to frozen but actually that they
think about their ap Isis products that
they sell to a customer they have to
think about who the customer is for
their API so mag Alou has to think about
if I'm gonna offer an API for
third-party vendors to sell stuff
my network of stores what kind of
technologies those vendors have what are
they gonna have to do in order to
actually get on my platform what can I
do to reduce the friction and how do I
keep track of that so it actually
affects my business
similarly AccuWeather has to think about
if people are going to build mobile apps
or other kind of digital experiences on
my services what kind of technology do I
have to offer what kind of api's do you
have to offer in other words these
companies that have done successful
things in their business with api's have
done it because they treat their API as
as products they have product managers
the product managers look at who the
customer segmentation is they look at
analytics and statistics to see which
API is our most popular and they
introduce new API is a new API
capabilities not based on what would be
cool but based on what's actually done
by you know what actually the numbers
they're seeing they they have a way of
becoming data-driven and this is
something that any company that does
product management knows how to do but a
lot of companies that are entering into
the API world from sort of an enterprise
entered integration perspective aren't
used to thinking that way they're
thinking about I need to solve a
business problem a need to solve a
technology probably wouldn't it be cool
if we could do this but the companies
that are successful with API are
thinking we have customers out there
our customers are hotel chains who want
to build integrations with ticket
masters ticketing API what kind of
technology platform do they have what
features are they looking for how do I
engage with those customers and make it
easy for to sign up and these companies
essentially become there in the same
sort of enterprise sales business that
Google Cloud is in with managing
relationships with customers and make
you treating those API is just the way
we treat any other product so that's
about all I'm gonna say about the high
level of API is an API management but
we're now gonna do is keith is gonna
show us a little bit about it what what
it looks like to be a consumer of an API
and if we could switch to the demo
excellent thank you thanks Greg so we
heard a little bit about what these
customers are doing when they want to
produce API is share them with the world
what does it look like when you want to
consume one of these API s so let's
imagine you're an application developer
and you'd write like to write an
application so I wanted to write an
application that would look at
historical weather I started thinking
about weather in different places and
things like that and I thought it would
be nice to be able to go back and look
at historical weather so the application
I've written here you can come in and
you can put in a location in this case
I've typed in San Francisco when I hit
this find button up here it will find
weather stations that are near that
location and for each of those I can
select one and I can go back and look at
the weather history so I'm looking at
San Francisco downtown I've gone back to
1930 and it's pulled down a year of
weather for me the red line is the high
temperature in Fahrenheit blue line high
temp our low temperature and January on
the left and December on the right so
nice application very easy to write how
do they do this so as an application
developer really what I'm focused on is
the user experience and I just want the
data from somewhere and I don't want to
have to go through a lot of trouble to
get it so I found this data out on this
web page so this is an example of a
developer portal what I'm seeing here is
this company's developer experience so
as an application developer I'm going to
come out here and I'm gonna start
reading about what API is are available
what can I do with them and things like
that so as I come into here I'm gonna
look at looks like there's some API
products and some things to get me
started
looks like there's some sample code in
here that might help me be able to use
these things I'm gonna come down and
look at let's try this weather history
try it out provides 100 calls per day
for a developer looks great so as I come
into here I'm gonna find that I've got a
whole list of API is in here I've got
one that will look up particular weather
stations and I've got one that'll get me
temperature data or wind data the first
one I want to try is this weather
station thing and they have a nice
little try it out over here and some
documentation so I would read through
this and if we're thinking like a
developer the goal is okay how do I get
data from this as quickly as possible
what kind of things do I need to do how
do I get authenticated how do I call
this so for this it looks like there is
an API key required and then we're gonna
provide some sort of street address or
place
so let's go up and register I'm already
logged in here I'm gonna register an
application and that gives me an API key
let's call this next demo okay and we're
going to go with this try it out here
and then I'm gonna come up here and hit
create and that's registered my
application so once my application is
registered
I've given I've been given credentials
that I can try for this I've got a key
in a secret I'm gonna come down here and
I'm going to cut and paste that key next
thing I want to do is I'm gonna go back
to my API sand I'm gonna try this out so
now that I have my key let's go into
here and let's try San Francisco again
and that's gonna pull down some weather
stations that are near me and it's a
demo there they are
okay so I've got back a series of
weather stations so there's the latitude
and longitude that matched San Francisco
it went out to Google Maps
it found that latitude and longitude
brought it back and I'm searching for
weather stations that are near that
point and it looks like there's a few in
there and there they are so I'm gonna
grab this first one here and then we're
gonna go over to here and it looks like
we can get temperature and wind data for
that particular weather station
so let's look up historical temperature
data grab an API key
and let's go back a few years let's go
back to let's say 1950 and it's a demo
okay we'll go back to our key let's try
this one by the way we will be deleting
all these API keys this is gonna be on
YouTube okay now it works my API key was
a little bit stale there so I have got
weather data back for this particular
weather station that year and then
there's a whole array of 365 days of
weather data so that was pretty easy to
do I could take that and I could build
an application from it so now we've
impersonated an API consumer yes now
we're gonna go behind the curtains a
little bit and impersonate an API
product manager yes basically how would
you as a company that wants to offer
such an API make the sign-on experience
for your customers as easy as what Keith
just showed and how do you actually as a
product manager what do you do how do
you actually keep track of who's using
your API right so I've configured some
things in here to productize these api's
I want to think about I've got a set of
services but how do I turn those into a
package that I can share I have
different people who want to consume
them and I might want to package them
different ways because different people
have different rights to these let's
imagine I've got a bunch of partners
some of them are allowed to do some
things others are allowed to do other
things and I want to control how
frequently they can call this I want to
play some rate limits on there and
things like that so I've packaged these
up into these products that we see here
what I'm really concerned about daily
though is what are the analytics look
like who's calling them what are they
doing how can I improve my API program
so for that I'm gonna come in and we're
gonna look at a few different reports in
here so I'm now playing the role of an
API manager and what I might do on a
daily basis is come in and look at some
of these reports so what I'm seeing here
is my proxy performance and I can see
traffic rolling into here and I get an
idea of you know the most basic metric
here how many people are calling this
thing and what are they doing so there's
traffic average response time traffic by
proxy average response time by proxy
another thing I might be interested
is looking at let me restart these some
our demos better okay another thing I
might want to look at is developer
engagement and that's gonna show me
who's called here so how many people
have called this what have they done in
that sort of thing
let's jump add to one that's loaded so
another thing it's really important
let's look at devices so I want to know
who's on iOS who's on Windows
who's on Android that sort of thing this
might influence how I'm going to build
my my mobile apps and things like that
so this reports gonna show me who's
coming in and what they're doing and how
much traffic I have by device I may come
in and want to look at a map and the map
would show me where all my traffic is
coming from and I can zoom in and I can
look at a particular location and get an
idea of who's calling from where so I've
got some traffic coming from California
not unexpected but I can get an idea of
where people are calling from the
latency from those different locations
and things like that
I might want to create a custom report
and in this custom report I'm gonna look
at traffic by weather station so maybe
have a curiosity just to know where are
people searching for these weather
stations which ones are interesting and
what are they pulling up so there's a
number of metrics that are provided for
me and I've also collected a custom
metric that I grabbed all the requests
and that was the particular weather
stations are looking for and that's
what's shown on this report
so that's a quick tour of what I might
do as an API product manager when I look
through all these different analytics
cool thanks so we've talked a little bit
and we can go back to the slides now
we've talked a little bit about what it
would look like to be the consumer of an
API basically what we saw was gee it was
really easy to sign up to get a key to
get credentials and start calling that
API we also looked a little bit at what
it would look like to be an API product
manager if I'm an API product manager
what do I do
how do I actually manage the people who
are using my API and that's really
important because the companies that
have succeeded with api's have treated
them with as products and really taken
that product management discipline to
heart we're gonna get back to some of
the technology later but we're going to
move on a little bit and we're going
talk a little bit about some of the high
level technologies you need to
understand in order to run a successful
API program what are some specific
things that make API as an API
management sort of a different kind of
technology than other things that are
out there well the first thing is is
what I've been calling a lot API
consumer management but it's really API
management API management is a set of
technology that manages the relationship
between the consumers of an API and the
producers of an API and it's really the
only bit of technology in the enterprise
that does that it's extremely important
for these kinds of use cases we've been
talking about because it's the only way
for an API product manager to understand
who was using their API how much are
they using their API and allows them to
create products that actually comprised
the API is that allow you to have
different offerings so in Keith's demo
there was a free developer version of
the weather app that you could call 200
times a day and presumably if we had
clicked farther maybe if he wanted to
launch an app on the App Store and have
a hundred million API calls a day on
that same API he would probably have
some way on that form to speak to the
API product manager directly and
negotiate Terms of Service or prices or
whatever sophisticated companies and
companies that have large numbers of API
is inside their companies use the API
management product not only to manage
relationships with external partners but
also internally if you want to be able
to say offer an API within a large
financial services organization and let
anybody in the organization use your API
you need a way for them to sign up get
credentials you may have API so that you
want to make visible only to certain
teams you may eventually want to make
those API is visible externally and you
may want have certain partners who have
access to certain API s and certain
partners that don't many companies that
have been running API is for many years
in production need these kind of
capabilities and rather than build a lot
of these things ad hoc and from scratch
if some companies do products in API
management products actually exists that
basically give you a way to manage all
this stuff so I really want to
talk about API is an API management I
spend a lot of time on this because to
me this is what API management is it's
technology to manage that relationship
between producers and consumers but
there are other parts to API management
as well that are really important in
that in order to run a successful API
it's important to understand one of them
is OAuth ooofff is the de facto standard
for access control for mobile
applications and really any kind of
applications and it's even used free a
single sign-on via Web Apps if you're
using an app that uses a Google API
you're using OAuth if you're using a
website that uses these api's or if
you're signing into Twitter or if you're
at work and you clicked on your internal
link that signs you into your health
insurance account and the web browser
redirects 47 times that's also OAuth
ooofff has become this de-facto standard
and also it's a set of IETF standards
because it makes possible to decouple
the different parts of the identity
relationship it allows the API gateway
which is usually a proxy that's sitting
in between the clients and the backends
to actually look at access tokens and
decide whether an API call should be
accepted or rejected and it allows that
API gateway to be separate from the
identity system that actually signs in
the user so that's why when you see
websites that have sign in via Google
sign in via Facebook or sign in via
github all of that is done using OAuth
and people build open API sand and
mobile applications using that same
technology and an interesting thing
about OAuth is that each ooofff token
which is the thing that your mobile
device actually sends when it makes an
API call to identify you not only is
unique so at a tell you identifies a
certain device it identifies the user
who signed in using the IDP in order to
get the token but it also identifies the
application that made the request so the
reason why off is so important to API
management is going back to this slide
here because each ooofff token
identifies the consumer of the API
exactly what application built the API
this can be really important we've seen
cases for instance where
a customer launches an API and they have
a problem in production because a new
version of a client application has gone
out of control do any kind of numbers
and is sending thousands of requests a
second to the API from phones all over
the world well without understanding
exactly which application is making that
request there's not much you can do
about it but if you have an API
management system in or it's wired up to
your OAuth you might be able to say take
all the requests from this application
and blackhole them to another server or
even reject them entirely at the API
gateway layer so they don't bring down
the rest of my infrastructure two other
really important bits of API management
one of them are quotas quotas are
something we see in every API today
those of you who are Google cloud
customers and they hope you will all be
Google cloud customers are probably
frustrated with the fact that quotas
exists but they're essential for any
company that offers a platform Google
has quotas on its cloud a fee is to
prevent for instance someone putting
their credentials in github and getting
picked up there and used to spin the
hundred thousand virtual machines for
Bitcoin mining I would say that never
happens but it totally happens similarly
we have quotas to protect us against
those sorts of things anyone who has an
API in production you need quotas if
you're gonna let people sign up for your
API for self-service why do you want to
do that you want to do that because that
self surface that we saw any developer
can click a button and use an API within
five minutes it only works if you have
some way to control the amount of
traffic coming into your API so that a
new user doesn't overwhelm your capacity
and you can't do that unless you have a
quota and unless you have an API
management system that can let you
control which application is using your
API and by how much
good quota systems that you set all
kinds of quotas and also let you do
things like reset them have different
levels of service for different
customers and change them so for
instance if you actually do need a
hundred thousand VMs on Google cloud
there's a way that you can ask a Google
support person to increase your quota
because now we know who you are we trust
you and we know you're not doing Bitcoin
mining so these are the kinds of things
that become really important when you
run api's at scale security threats are
a big deal of course ooofff is a big
part of security but API gateways are
very important for security but they
operate at they'll at the highest level
they're able to tell you if an API call
has a legitimate access token or it
comes from a legitimate application but
there are other kinds of security
threats as well for instance let's
imagine that Keith had amended his API
to let you send in using some sort of
JSON payload what the weather is now hey
you know it's actually raining in San
Francisco your app told me it was sunny
well a whole lot of things could go
wrong with that right
um to start with the description of the
weather might not be something that they
want to publish but that's that's a
different problem
but yeah you're accepting JSON from
untrusted people on the Internet so
what's to stop someone from sending you
a 100 megabyte comment not that JSON has
comments but a 100 megabytes string or
something that's less than 10000 levels
deep or instead of your weather station
ID they put in you know semicolon you
know delete star from customers or
something like that all of these kinds
of threats are real and can happen when
you're accepting data like JSON or XML
or something else so an untrusted party
and it's really important to be able to
protect against those things so a lot of
API gateways can do that as well I'll
also mention DDoS a lot of people say oh
I need an API gateway they protect me
from DDoS attacks the truth is that API
gateway technology is essential for
these kinds of things because of quotas
because I of authentication but that's
got to be a fully multi-layered approach
so that's why we have DDoS protection
built into Google cloud we have
additional products like cloud armor
that gives you more sophisticated DDoS
protection but there are many layers
necessary in any kind of internet facing
products to protect against those
finally I mentioned one part of API
management that's not really as tightly
connected to the others but it's
something that becomes very important in
the real world which is mediation and
transformation and integration many of
the examples I used at the beginning of
this presentation where companies that
created new digital experiences on top
of legacy systems
because almost everybody out there in
the world has legacy systems
well those legacy systems usually don't
present the kind of API that for
instance the Google home device expects
or that a mobile application developer
is using they may return
you know 25k of XML when what a mobile
app really needs is 200 bytes of JSON
they may not have been designed for the
Internet era and may not even
contemplate being used by hundreds of
thousands or millions of people their
response time may be low so it can be
very very important to be able to use
something like an API gateway to mediate
and transform different technologies so
you can take that soap application
that's been in production for 15 years
build an API on it and then be able to
use it to launch a new digital
experience this even goes sort of in the
forward direction developers who are
building things with micro-services
today love to use technology like G RPC
it's efficient it's easily integrated
with certain programming languages it
kind of it's easier to develop depending
on young the context but often if you're
doing something like talking to a mobile
app you want to transform that into
something like JSON over HTTP which is
something that all developers can
understand and an increasing number of
api gateways do that as well so let me
take a few minutes here and talk about
our products but so far I've been
talking about API management API
management companies who actually do ap
is and what it can do in particular
sorry in a generic way let me talk about
what we have to offer at Google Google
actually offers two products in the
world of API management these are both
actually owned by the same team and I'm
responsible for the architecture of both
of them cloud endpoints has been a part
of Google cloud for a while the
advantage of cloud endpoints is that it
is a very small simple fast easy to
setup
products that gives you the basics of
API management you can verify an API key
you can you can set a quota you can do
some basic authentication a lot of
companies use cloud endpoints in order
to build digital experiences in front of
workloads that already run on Google
Cloud it takes advantage of many of the
API capable
that are built into google cloud such as
the quotas and authentication you're
already using if you're at Google cloud
customer the other product we have is
Apogee Apogee was acquired by Google in
late 2016
it's what I've primarily been working on
for the last third of my career and then
one of Apogee does basically everything
around API management not only running
as a basic API gateway to do things like
authentication but also there's things
like a customizable developer portal a
highly sophisticated and customizable
quota mechanism caching API monitoring
customizable API analytics monetization
so if you choose to charge money for an
API you can use Apogee to assign a value
to particular API calls and then
generate a bill for customers later and
many companies especially larger
enterprises that have a lot of these
companies enterprise complexities to
them find that they need the
sophistication of an API management
product like Apogee in order to really
solve their problems so the ones who
were saying hey you know the foreign
exchange to forum in shouldn't be able
to call the equity trading departments
API is unless it's approved by a VP you
know these are the kinds of things that
happen in the real world and they make
API management more than just checking
an API key in a redish table but
actually doing some more sophisticated
roles based access controls these are
the kinds of things that a lot of
customers use Apogee to do it's
important to mention that Apogee
actually runs in multiple modes one of
them is software as a service everything
runs by Google in the cloud in all of
Google's data centers other end of the
spectrum is on-premises you can take the
whole thing and put it in your own data
center and not touch the Internet at all
there's a number of companies who have
historically had to do that for a whole
number of reasons what we're seeing now
is is even more and more people need to
be able to run in multi cloud and in a
hybrid environment and obviously you've
heard a lot about that at the conference
already today so Apogee also has a
hybrid mode for the API gateway that
actually sits in between the client and
server of the API traffic can run on
your own data center or your own cloud
are really anywhere you want it to be
while some of the other parts of Apogee
like the
management and the analytics can run as
a service run by us and with that said
Keith is now going to show us how to
actually build the api's that he showed
and apply the API management
capabilities he showed using Apogee and
sorry can we go to the demo there we go
so we talked about how people consume
this but what did it take to build this
service so we saw that we have this nice
weather application with all this data
on here where's the data coming from and
what's behind this so let me talk about
how I built that using Apogee so what we
have in here is on the left hand side
there you see a client application and
it uses API keys to talk to the back-end
system the data is out in bigquery and
I've got one of the public datasets out
there is historical weather and it has
weather going back a few hundred years
and I thought it'd be kind of cool to
use that but the challenges I ran into
was I need to authenticate with Google
Cloud and to do that I have to go get an
access token there's some credentials
that need to be exchanged in there and
they need to send a header to the
backend so that process isn't really
important to who's consuming this on the
consumption side of this I wanted to
have API keys so I could identify
different applications
I could onboard people pretty quickly so
what we're seeing in here is the left
side of this is one set of security the
right side is a different set of
security I also had some other concerns
in there some of the things that Greg
mentioned some of the things we worry
about as we start to share data with new
people and those are things like how do
I build a facade on this back-end
so I want to take everything that's back
there no matter when it was written and
make it look clean and new to the
consumers of this so I want to change
the request in response that are coming
back and forth in there I wanted to
control access to some features so you
can try it out for free and you can get
a hundred calls if you're a valued
partner maybe you can come in and you
can look at more things if you have a
different relationship with us I wanted
a rate limit to protect the backend so
we need to have things in there so that
if your application has a loop in there
that's uncontrolled we don't want to
melt the backend for everybody we want
to shut you down so rate limiting and I
want to impose some quotas for business
reasons I want to have different tiers
of service for different people so that
I could charge accordingly
and I want to add caching in here so if
somebody makes the same request twice
let's just call it from memory and let's
not go all the way to the back end and
reformat the request in the response so
that's what I built that's what this
diagram represents let's look at what's
behind this so how did that get there so
the next role for me to play here as the
demo person is we're gonna look at what
does it take to build and manage a
service that you want to expose to other
people so I started off with a
specification and I thought about I know
it's in the database I know how that's
formatted but what do I want to present
to the outside world and for that I
wrote this back in open API spec I did
this in Apogee I've come in here and
I've described what the endpoints are
I've described the data formats and
things like that
I did that in this left-hand pane on the
right hand side here I can see a
rendering of what my documentation will
look like so that was the documentation
we saw it on the website this is what
guided developers on how to use it the
next thing I did was I took that spec
and I turned it into an API proxy and
Appaji and what this does is this is
going to control that request and
response flow that goes back and forth
what we see in here is there's a URL up
here I'm going to start calling inside
of appaji and that's going to call this
big query query API on the back end if I
click over here on develop what I'm
gonna see in here is a graphical
depiction of the request and response
flow so what we're seeing is this is the
request coming in on the top right up
here and then we see the response coming
back on the bottom and I'm gonna do a
few things along the way to manage this
request and response flow for example
I'm gonna come in and I'm gonna do some
rate limiting and right down here I'm
gonna limit them to 10 calls per minute
that's not very fast but it's something
I can demonstrate
breaking in a demo so these different
policies are run on the request side
these policies are run on the response
side I have different flows in here that
can do different things I've got a whole
set of policies over here that when I
click that plus button they'll get added
things for traffic management how do we
control just the basic flow going back
and forth and they're things for
security as we start to share with new
people we're always concerned about
security so basic auth to check for
usernames and passwords
ooofff as Greg mentioned to tie into our
identity management system and to
identify who's calling I might want to
reformat things
might want to turn my JSON into xml XML
to JSON if I've got a legacy system on
the back end I may want to extend this
with Java call-outs Python calls or
JavaScript or I might want to take
advantage of certain things in Google
cloud by using some of these extensions
that are specific so those are all
different policies I might add in there
that manages my request in my response
flow and then depending on how this is
called depending on what people put at
the end of the URL I might want to do
different things so if looking for a
weather station I might execute these
things first thing we do in there is
look up an API key that's gonna give me
access to Google Maps and I'm gonna use
that to make a call-out and look up that
city so when I type in San Francisco
what I'm really looking for is the
latitude and longitude of San Francisco
because that's how the weather stations
are in my database I'm gonna look at the
response of that I'm gonna grab the
latitude and longitude out of that I'm
gonna draw a nice little box around that
with some code and figure out an area
where I want to search for weather
stations that's right there and then
finally I'm gonna big build up a big
query request and I'm gonna completely
request I'm gonna completely replace
this request with a whole new body and
send that in and this is completely
hidden from my consumer when I get the
response back I'm gonna format the
response that comes back to look at some
they could look more pleasing and more
useful to my developer so those are all
different things that I would do in here
to build this up so I'm gonna send in
request them to see responses now along
the way it's possible remotely possible
that I made a mistake in my code and I
need to debug this so I'm gonna come in
and I'm going to show what it looks like
to debug in here what I've done is I've
turned on trace in here and this is
gonna let me look at detailed request
response flow in here so I'll come back
over to my weather application and we'll
go back to let's go back just to 2015
and we'll send a request in there to
look up temperature data and I'll send
in a few and this should shut me down
after a bit because I'm being rate
limited so if we come back over to here
we'll see those rolling in and we can
see a detailed response of exactly what
happened in there so here's the requests
coming in we can see all the details of
what was received by the client we can
see API keys being processed metadata
being loaded to describe who the person
is we see our rate limit in here come
you'll notice over here that we see a
429 air we've applied rate-limiting
because this person was calling too
quickly so what they're gonna see in
that case is they're going to see a nice
air that says call rate exceeded this
application is limited to ten requests
per minute so instead of seeing that big
500 something horrible happen and we
don't know what it is you're gonna see a
helpful error that's going to help you
debug your application so that's what I
did to build this this was easy for me I
had a back-end system I made a few calls
to it I figured out what the format was
I thought about how do I want to manage
that I went into Apogee in here I built
an API proxy and then that's how people
are gonna call this so that's a quick
example of how you build something in
Apogee and exactly what the steps are to
do that cool so in the beginning we
showed you what what it might look like
to be the consumer of an API then we
talked a little bit at what it would
look what it would look like to be an
API product manager and now keith is
showing us what does it look like to
actually use apogee to create the
policies in order to make the API work
the way that I wanted to now if we could
go back to the slides for a second
something we didn't mention at the
beginning which is that we have this
really nifty way not that way that way
of having you ask questions this is an
internal Google tool using it next for
the first time it's called Dory um after
I think after the character in the show
but anyway and I see that we didn't tell
you about this because no one has asked
any questions um so this is a great way
to ask questions because it lets you
type in your question on your mobile
device by going to the link that's in
the next app for this particular session
and the cool thing about it is that if
your neighbors ask tedious questions you
can vote them down or if they ask really
good questions you can vote them up so I
we have only a few more minutes till the
sessions over but we will also look when
the session is over at what questions
are on there and we'll answer them
online if people ask them later I wanted
to mention two more things before we
were done one of them is that we
actually do and this is not a product
announcement this is not a product
announcement session but we actually
have announced a couple of products
today um I mentioned hybrid earlier for
Apogee hybrid is a way that you can take
the API gateway part of Apogee which is
what keith was just demoing and run that
anywhere you want including your own
data center while the rest of Apogee
such as the API Analytics the API
product management and all those kinds
of things including some of the user
interface runs in Google's cloud this is
something our customers have been asking
us for for a long time because many many
customers even if they are completely
bought into cloud computing many of them
still have and may have for a long time
to come
stuff that runs in their own data
centers or even and other clouds or on
private clouds so Apogee hybrid gives
you a way to do this that is in data
starting today we also have something
called API security reporting which is
based on some of the analytics that
Keith showed it gives you a little bit
more details about how your API traffic
is behaving and it alerts you the things
like anomalous API traffic or even
mistakes you might have made like not
configuring TLS properly for your api's
and finally some of the policies that
Keith showed and that policy editor are
actually things that you can extend
yourself using a capability called
Apogee extensions there are pre-built
extensions for many popular integration
technologies like s ap like many of the
Google cloud API is and yes also many of
the Amazon API is because many of you
use Amazon API is as well Apogee
extensions is fully GA now it's been
part of the Apogee product for a little
while last thing when I mentioned before
we go to questions is that we have a
whole lot of sessions related to AP is
and API management here at cloud this
session will be videotaped I can't give
you the slides but it will be on YouTube
it won't be videotaped it'll be recorded
and it'll be on YouTube will be
recording on 8-millimeter film and but
if you want to take a picture of this a
lot of it the the companies that I
mentioned who are actually doing things
with api's such as AccuWeather and mag
Allu are going to be presenting here at
next Woolies x is the sort of the
experimental arm of Woolworths in
Australia they do a lot with api's and
digital technology as the skies are
permanentiy Equifax HP turbine science
so if I apologize for in any of the
sessions being full but it does seem
like if you you know our patient you can
get in after
the first 10 or 15 minutes so if you're
looking to learn more about API is an
API management how then that's that's a
great thing to do I've got a few
questions on the dory yeah I can yeah
we're not gonna present them because we
don't want to out people's names but
we're gonna start and yeah well let's
ask if answer a few of the questions so
first question here how do you manage
API versions so this one comes up almost
every time I demo this product so
there's there's two concepts here one is
basic revisions in the API proxy so
let's say I add caching but I'm not
changing the contract of how this calls
back and forth there is a built-in
revision assistant within Apogee to
manage the revisions of those API
proxies you saw me manipulating the
other thing is versioning let's say I
break that contract and I'm gonna change
the format that comes back completely
there are many ways to do this Apogee
supports all kinds of ways to do this
the most common we're seeing is that
people will put v1 or v2 or v3 in the
URL as far to the left as possible and
you can deploy this API proxy you can
make a copy of it and deploy a new one
to call that version 2 and it can behave
differently you can tie the analytics to
that so you can measure who's on version
1 who's on version 2 much better than
the old way which is just to turn off
one and see who gets angry so this is
better and you can also find out who's
using that old version of the API so yes
you can maybe even send them an email
and say what's going on or slow them
down
ok a little motivation yeah so that's
how we would do versioning in here and
you can keep iterating on there you can
measure it and do it formally so the
nice feature of that let me see what
else is in here umm someone asked about
open API 3 I actually thought that we
either did that or we're about to do it
so I'll it is on the roadmap I don't
know if we can give details but ok
record us and everything but it's on the
roadmap ok
let's see why would anyone use Cloud
endpoints um I really should be able
answer this question right now um one of
the advantage of Cloud endpoints is it's
very simple to get started with it's
also very inexpensive so it does a few
things but it does them well when it
does them at a very low cost this can be
very important if you have because what
we see for instance is companies have
very sophisticated API programs with
lots of bells and whistles and complex
transformations and things but that may
be for low volume things for a consumer
application that's called
hundreds of millions or billions of
times a day sometimes you may only need
a basic quota and an API key check and
Cloud endpoints can do that and it can
do that at a low price point and we're
actually can we are we are continuing to
develop Cloud endpoints we're gonna see
actually over the next year or two some
more enhancements to it and over time
Cloud endpoints and Apogee will be more
will will will be happy together
sorry my my app crashed okay another one
you want to take I see another one in
here asking about graph QL API support
so this is coming up more and more where
people are asking about this you can
send anything that's HTTP back and forth
it doesn't necessarily have to be rest
so people use this with soap I've seen
people use it with OData and other
protocols they're gonna add on top of
that we're looking at how to support
graph QL we don't have anything in there
today but it is something we're
definitely looking at but feel free to
use it with graph QL today you will find
value in that and we've seen a few
patterns on how to support it well with
a purging right um can all of this be
configured via frameworks such as
serverless or a RC that codes I don't
know an IRC that codes is I don't think
serverless is working with Apogee
equably if I people talk about it
everything in Apogee however is done via
API yeah so what many people have done
so for instance you showed doing things
with a GUI but when most people do is
they have there's a maven plugin and an
ant plug who maybe not know when he says
Anthony where there's a Jenkins plugin a
lot of people have built integrations
with the API is to automate the process
of defining api's and pushing them out
and that's an example of how you might
do that everything that is in the UI is
also supported through a API so our our
UI is built on top of this API so you
can also use those to automate that and
a lot of people will tie that into their
CI CD yeah how do I get onboard to
Apogee hybrid beta we should have a what
and some come talk to us in the hallway
afterwards and home may be an answer
that let's see can apogee be used to
manage a large inventory of api's with
thousands of internal users versus
external users we've definitely had
people do that we have a lot of people
didn't have hundreds of thousands of
consumers of their API s
does Apogee have a circuit breaker for
services that slow down it certainly
does we've got a spike arrest policy in
there that can be inserted in there so
that if it's called too frequently it
will shut them down and use the circuit
breaker pattern right someone asked
about using Apogee as a proxy between
internal micro services as well as
publishing them there are actually a
couple ways to do that there's a of the
API gateway called the micro gateway
which people sometimes co-locate with
lots of services so that they can run it
they can have lots of little api
gateways instead of a few big ones
also there is integration between Apogee
and Sto so if you're running an sto
service mesh and if there's no one at
this conference running an sto service
mesh you definitely have them here you
can actually plug Apogee into the sto
mixer so that once sto is managing your
services in the mesh you can use Apogee
for quota for API key verification and
we're making some progress on ooofff as
well the use case for that is I have a
number of services running in sto and
sto by the way is a part of the new
cloud services platform that has a name
that I've already forgotten I'm sorry um
but anyway Apogee sto is part of that if
you have this do and you have services
in the sto mesh let's imagine you want
to turn one or two of those services
into api's publish them to users outside
that service mesh and use the developer
portals or quotas API keys and OAuth
stuff that we showed you in the demos
today you can do that in this deal right
now by integrating SPO with Apogee
weather Apogee is on-premises hybrid or
in the cloud we're running low on time I
would take one more question from the
dory here and then I think we'll wrap up
so what have you is asking how do you
get free access to a pudgy so go to
Apogee comm in the upper right you'll
see a nice free trial you can click on
that button and sign up for a trial
account and you can try out and build
things so we're gonna wrap it up now the
next session starts very soon we can
hang around outside for questions
there's also an Apogee booth in the expo
area where there are a lot of people
there who are experts who can talk to
you we'd be happy to talk more to you
and then we'll look it back on a few of
the Dory questions as well so thank you
for coming enjoy your next sessions
thank you all
[Music]